The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality,
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GANG CHEN: OK.
I hope you all had a
wonderful Valentine's Day.
I share you a story.
I always make those
reservations and put something
on my calendar.
So I put on calendar
my last slide.
I give a public lecture
at Boston University.
It turns out, my sponsor,
myself none of us
know this, what's
date [? night ?] like?
So you can imagine how
many people showed up
on this public lecture.
There was one interesting, in
fact, an interesting couple.
And they were sitting
in my lecture.
And I was talking about
the [INAUDIBLE] electrics.
And after that, I
had a chat with them.
And his wife actually said,
oh, today's his birthday too.
So birthday and Valentine's
Day, so I was very pleased.
So coming back,
last time, we were
talking about a very raw picture
of the microscopic energy
carriers.
We say, OK, if we look
at the molecule, what
are the energy, how
much energy they have?
What are the forms of energy?
And then we say
how many we have?
Particularly, we introduced
the Boltzmann factor,
the statistics.
And say, what's the
average energy of the kT.
So they taken translation
as one example.
And if you think about the
kT, if it's a molecule,
you can use the mass 1/2
mv squared equals kT.
And you can actually say the
molecular speed is very high.
The molecule is moving
a few meters per second,
except they are
doing random motion.
And then we see how
far they travel.
That's the mean free path.
We estimate the air
molecule, the mean free path
is above the 100 nanometer.
And with that, we give a
very simple derivation,
kinetic picture of the
transport, the Fourier
law of heat conduction.
And at the end, we went
into the size effects.
So if you transport the
characteristic length is
less than the mean free path,
or less than the wavelength
of the [INAUDIBLE]
wave, you will
get say either classic or size
effect or quantum size effect.
And now that I went through the
quantum side effect very evenly
and also that the
end of lecture.
So hopefully, today
we can make that up.
And in today's lecture, I'll be
talking about materials waves
and energy quantization.
And this is a chapter two.
So today and next
Monday, use two lectures.
And we'll go through
quantum mechanics.
So that's ambition there.
So what I want you to
get is some basic ideas
of appreciation for the
importance of energy
quantization.
And say, you see with
this very simple view,
you can actually
understand a lot of things.
So let's start with the wave.
I said in the last lecture
when you have an interface,
because the interface thickness
of the characteristic length
is zero.
So it's always good to say
what other wave you have
[? reflecting, ?] other waves.
So let's start with
the general wave.
You all have learned about
waves in one form or another.
What are the most important
characteristics of waves?
What are the basic
characteristics of these waves?
You have face.
Let's say go even more basic.
Amplitude,
wavelength, frequency.
So basic characteristics
of waves.
And when we think
about the frequency,
we're thinking
about time domain.
And when we think
about the wavelengths,
we're thinking
about space domain.
So if we-- say I have a wave,
simple wave, a sine wave.
Here is the period.
And in the case of time
domain, this period is time.
In the case of space domain,
this is the wavelength.
So time period or wavelengths.
But we normally do not
like to write time period.
We like to talk about frequency.
So can anyone tell me what's
the relation between frequency
and time period?
Mathematics, now.
It's a Fourier transform.
So if you have
purely a function,
if you have Fourier
transform, the universe
is 2 pi over that period.
So we have period and frequency.
This is the Fourier pair.
Of course, frequency is
a 2 pi over the period.
So at least in
time domain, you're
very comfortable
with the frequency.
And in space domain,
we have wavelengths.
What's the corresponding
Fourier inverse?
I'm sorry?
Wave number.
That's probably less
familiar, you don't use often.
So the wave number, eta
equals 2 pi over lambda
It's a Fourier pair, right?
And of course, when we
talk about frequency,
there is another
frequency we often use.
Angular frequency.
So omega is an angular
frequency is 2 pi new.
And correspondingly, I
have a k equals 2 pi eta,
or is 2 pi over lambda.
OK, this is a free space.
AUDIENCE: Nu would be 1 over T.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, nu [INAUDIBLE].
GANG CHEN: Nu-- you
were, I'm sorry.
OK, yes, sorry, sorry.
Now all this has a problem.
1 over T, and otherwise,
we might have 2 pi, there.
Thank you.
But the space is more
complex than time.
Space has direction.
So when a wave traveling in a
certain direction, I can say,
this is the wavelength in
that specific direction.
I can have kx, ky, kz.
So here, K, in general,
is a wave vector.
So it's a kx, ky, kz.
So we have wave vector.
I want to be consistently
using capital.
So this K is the magnitude
of the wave vector.
So now we have the
space, we have the time,
basic characteristics
that characterize
a wave, its periodicity.
And now we can write
this simplest wave,
simple form of a wave.
The simplest way is a
sine wave or cosine wave,
constant amplitude.
So let's write it a simple wave.
And I'll write using
general symbol, phi.
And this could be a vector.
It could be a vector wave.
Think about, acoustic
wave is the vector wave.
The electromagnetic
wave is a vector wave.
So a vector that
has an amplitude,
and I write a
constant amplitude.
And I have a time, omega
t, minus k, times x.
You can go to say, substitute
omega equal 2 pi nu, k
is 2 pi over lambda.
So this is a wave traveling
in the x direction.
And then I have a unit
vector represent this vector.
When I say the direction, that's
the wave traveling direction.
So I have two directions there.
One is the wave
traveling direction.
The other is the wave
oscillation direction.
If you think about the
electromagnetic field,
the wave is traveling forward.
And we know electromagnetic
field is the transverse wave,
so electric field is
perpendicular to the wave
traveling direction.
If you think about the
acoustic wave, the sound wave,
it's a longitudinal wave.
So the wave vector
is propagating
to you and the oscillation,
the pressure wave
is also in the same direction.
Longitudinal wave.
So I have two directions.
And this I associate a
polarization of the wave.
And this x is the direction,
the wave propagation direction.
And this is the field, y
is the field direction.
So this is the simple
wave, of course,
a, here is the amplitude.
And somebody
mentioned the phase.
So phase of the wave
is what's inside.
So omega t minus kx,
that's the phase.
And for a constant phase, so a
plan of a certain phase value,
and if this is a constant,
that's a constant phase plan.
And you can see
this plan is moving
at dx dt equals omega
over k, from here.
Take a derivative.
So that's the velocity
of the constant phase.
So this is called
the phase velocity.
And of course, the
most common relation,
you probably familiar,
is the light.
Where you have for
light in vacuum,
we know frequency
times wavelengths
is the speed of light.
I use a small c, or here,
let's put a constant.
And so speed of light, and
this we say, omega equals ck.
For light, it's a linear
relation between omega and k
in free space.
But more generally, as
you will see very soon,
there is a very complex
relation between omega and k,
in general.
So omega and k, in
general case, could
be a very complicated
function of the wave vector.
And what that means is
in different direction,
the wavelengths and frequency
have very complex relationships
And this is particularly true
when we go to solids, photons,
and electrons.
So that's just a warning
down this street.
And so here we talk about phase,
we talk about sine wave here.
But in mathematical operation,
if you take a derivative
of sine, what do you get?
Cosine, right?
And that's not convenient, even
though it's a simple enough.
A simpler derivative
where it goes to itself
is the exponential function.
So very often rather
than representing a wave
in sine and cosine, I'm
going to represent it
in exponential functions.
So this is a complex
representation.
That's really for
mathematical convenience.
And if I use a complex
representation,
I will write this wave as--
I can combine a and y
into a vector, that's
the wave oscillation direction.
And then I will write
exponential minus i, omega t.
So I use a complex,
omega t minus k times x.
First I do 1D.
So if you say this,
of course, it's
easier to take a derivative
of exponential function.
And what I have
here really means I
can write this exponential
back into cosine and sine.
So I have cosine, omega
t minus k, x minus i,
sine omega t minus k, x.
So I have a real part
and an imaginary part.
And in real life, of
course, the waves normally
is either sine and cosine.
So the [? case, ?]
you stick to say, OK,
if my solution-- if my
initial condition, my boundary
condition, all is for the real
part, cosine, then at the end
after I solve my problem in
this complex representation,
my real power solution
is what I'm looking for.
If you stick to
the imaginary part,
again, you have to look at
your initial, your boundary
condition.
And as long as you meet
the sign, those constraint,
you say the imaginary
part is your solution.
So that's this
complex representation
gives you mathematical
convenience.
A lot of commonalities,
if you look there,
I put a minus sign in the front.
That's just my preference.
It turns out that
even different book,
people sometimes use
positive, some use negative.
And particularly, when
you go to read optics,
some books use a positive,
some people use negative.
And that creates
a lot of confusion
because that will
mean later on, you
will see there is
an after constant
that has a real part
and imaginary part.
And in the front, it could
be positive or negative sign.
So unfortunately,
that's the case.
And we don't have
a solution there.
And the other comment
I want to say,
this waves are traveling waves.
Last lecture, I mentioned
is standing wave.
If you play guitar,
you clamp the two ends.
That's a standing wave.
And here is a wave
that traveling,
in this case, omega t minus kx
into the positive x direction.
If it's a plus kx,
that's the wave
traveling into the negative
direction, x direction.
More generalization, here is
a wave in the x direction.
But I said k is
generally a vector.
So if I write a
three dimensional,
plane wave and the
general form for this wave
is a, that's again, the
polarization direction.
And amplitude exponential
minus i, omega t minus k
is a vector dot r.
So this is a plane wave in
complex representation in 3D.
General space.
And we mentioned here
is a traveling wave.
And I can use traveling wave to
construct the standing waves.
Example, let's think
about standing wave.
So I have two opposing
traveling waves.
Same amplitude, one is
sine omega t minus kx.
So this is a wave traveling
to the positive x direction.
I have opposing wave traveling
in the negative direction, sin
plus kx.
So two traveling waves, now.
And I superimpose them
together, what do I get?
Add two sine.
It's two sines, sine, cosine.
So the negative part cancel.
So I will get 2A sin
omega t, cosine kx.
So now you can see I have--
standing wave because
these are my [INAUDIBLE]..
When the kx equal 0, it
doesn't depend on time.
So my zero point is fixed.
You play your guitar,
you press your finger,
and you fix your loads there.
So this day, I can
use the standing wave
to construct--
the traveling wave
to construct standing wave.
Last comment on wave.
What's the energy of
the wave, typically?
So energy of wave is typically
proportional to the square.
So the energy is typically
proportional to the square
of the wave.
The amplitude higher,
larger energy.
Those are the basic
characteristics.
So with this, let's go to
talk about material wave.
And we have to go into
the quantum mechanics.
Let's talk about how it started.
So this is a very interesting
history in science.
This is the study
about with the optics.
And you heard probably
Newton optics.
And of course, when
Newton did the optics,
he treated light as particles.
He didn't think
light was a wave.
And so it took a lot of
time to challenge Newton.
And there are [INAUDIBLE],, there
are a lot of people eventually
it was established light is
a wave, its not a particle.
The final triumph is
Maxwell equations for light.
So going from particle to wave.
And Maxwell equations solidify
the wave nature of light.
And that seems to be
all settled problem.
Except they say if you go to
look at the history of physics
and there are two problems
that people wrestle with.
One is black body radiation.
And it was found
through experiment
that this is the wavelength.
And this is the
emission from black body
at different wavelengths.
And this is a typical curve
of blackbody radiation.
And the classical mechanics
are for black body for light,
unfortunately, the trend
should be always like this.
So that was a big puzzle
for physicists at the time.
And the other is all relate
to photon is the hydrogen
absorption spectrum.
And it was observed
that absorption
happens at discrete lines.
And the continuing
mechanics say you
should have a
continuous spectrum,
but they say the
measurement actually
say that's not the case.
So to answer this puzzle,
a lot of people tried,
and it was Planck that first
introduced a radical concept.
And rather than-- when we talk
about electromagnetic wave,
we say the energy is
proportional to empty
the square.
It's a continuum.
You can have any amplitude.
So what Planck introduced
is that you cannot have any
continuous function of
that, say amplitude.
So your energy is not
a continuous function
and energy at specific
frequency can only be multiple
of this h nu.
And this h is the Planck
constant, is 6.6 10
to the minus 34 joule second.
n is an integer.
n is 0, 1, 2.
So the energy of the
light cannot be any value.
It has to be multiple
of this h nu.
So that was a radical concept,
discretization of energy.
And so what happened was
Einstein, as you know,
he was a patent clerk, he read
Planck's theory, blackbody.
And he did another
radical proposal.
And he say this means that
the electromagnetic wave is
granular.
It has particle characteristics.
So it came back to a particle.
Particle has energy
and the momentum.
So what's the momentum of light?
So Einstein has his famous
energy relation, mc squared.
And momentum p, is a mass
because the light is not
a particle that has mass.
So we need to get
rid of the mass.
And so is the mc, so we
have mc is mc squared divide
by c, that's the energy.
Energy is the h nu divided by c.
So it's h over lambda.
So Einstein argue that the
momentum of this light quanta
is actual lambda.
And now, the light has
both, say this basic quanta
has both an energy unit,
h nu and a momentum
unit of h over lambda.
So with that, he argued that
light, say, has a particle.
This is granular wave, it has
both a wave and a particle.
And in fact, if you go to
read Einstein paper in 1905--
he published four papers.
And one is relativity.
The other was on
Brownian motion.
Brownian motion
was his PhD thesis.
At the time, they didn't
know Brownian motion.
They didn't there was
a Browning observation.
He was just trying to infer
the size of atoms, molecules.
And then he hypothesis
this energy quanta.
And I wasn't sure the
other one was about this
is the photoelectric effect.
But I thought this one together
with the photoelectric effect.
Anybody remember?
Four papers.
So if the photoelectric effect
with this together is one
then I can only count three.
Maybe you go you
go back to check.
With this an energy
quanta concept,
he explained another
experimental observation.
That's the photoelectric effect.
And the photoelectric
effect is when you have
two electrode, metal electrode.
You shine light onto it.
You will have a current flow.
Current flow.
And the physics is that the
light drive electron out
of the metal.
So go from one electrode
to the other electrode.
But the puzzle was
that you should be--
the current should
be proportional
to the intensity of light.
So the more light that comes,
the higher current you have.
But the experimental
observations
is if the light wavelengths,
or say frequency,
wavelengths are too long,
or frequencies are too low,
it doesn't have current.
So there's a threshold for
this photoelectric effect.
And Einstein's explanation is
this is where electron sits.
Later on, we'll see
this is the Fermi level.
And here is the--
it needs to come out
of the metal to the vacuum.
And there you got a
difference in energy.
And this difference here is
vacuum, is the work function.
That's why you say
you have to have--
you to have this
energy quanta, h nu,
larger than the work function.
And it's like you
get a one ball,
you knock out another ball.
So this is the granular,
the consequence
of this granular
picture of light.
In fact, if you go to
check the Einstein papers,
so sometimes I joke,
he's a heat transfer guy.
If you go to check
Einstein papers, he really,
all those arguments were
based on thermodynamics.
If you think about the time,
there was no quantum mechanics.
And they only had the classical
mechanics and the Boltzmann,
at the best, the Boltzmann
[INAUDIBLE] for physics.
That was the foundation at the
time, and Maxwell equations.
So very interesting to
read those articles.
And it took, actually,
on this quanta of light,
it took Einstein another 10
years or so, to think more.
And came up with the idea
of a stimulated emission.
That's also further, say,
the light characteristics.
So with that, we
have basic relation,
Planck-Einstein relation.
The energy of the
quanta is h nu,
and the momentum of the
quanta is h over lambda.
And this is for EM wave.
And later on, at the time, they
didn't give the name photon.
So it wasn't until
1930's, somebody
suggested that this basic
energy quanta for light
is called the photon.
And so that's where Einstein
stopped on this photon.
And like I said, he said
stimulating emission, all that.
And then there was
a graduate student,
his name was de Broglie,
doing his PhD thesis.
And he looked at this
Planck-Einstein relation
for the quantum.
And there is going
from wave to particle.
And he made a very
bold, extrapolation.
He said why just for the
electromagnetic wave?
Why is not for any particle
that also has the reverse wave
characteristics?
So de Broglie further
extended this to matter waves.
He didn't have an equation.
He couldn't write a,
say, wave equation.
But I say, I have to admit, I
didn't go to read his thesis.
But I heard the
thesis was very short.
And it just says reverse
and make the argument.
And then people went
to do experiment.
And they experiment on that
was by Davisson and Germer.
So if we think about
the material wave,
let's take the wavelength
of matter is h over p.
And I can go to calculate
what's the wavelength?
And I take any
object to 1 kilogram.
And 1 meter per second,
what's the wavelength?
That's just the h, right?
p is mv, is 1.
And wavelength is
10 to the minus 34.
So I think this is probably
related to gravitational wave,
people are still
trying to establish
the relation between
gravitational waves
and the quantum
mechanics, all this.
But that's too short.
So your m is too large.
And but see, if you go
to take an electron,
the electron mass is
10 to the minus 31--
9.1-- 10 to the minus 31.
If electron was 1
meter per second,
the wavelength is very long
because 10 to minus 34,
divide 10 to minus 31, give
you 10 to the minus 3 meter.
That's a very long wavelength.
In fact, it's too long.
So the Davisson and
Germer experiment
was actually shooting
electrons-- yes?
AUDIENCE: Your velocity
is always relative?
GANG CHEN: Well, let's
say you should go to--
ideally, you should go
to relativistic velocity,
so when you go,
actually electron.
When you say relative
what do you mean?
Relative to each
other, or relative--
AUDIENCE: The first example
when you said 1 kilogram and 1
meter per second--
GANG CHEN: Right.
AUDIENCE: And 1 meter per
second is [INAUDIBLE]----
GANG CHEN: Relative to which
observation system, what they
mean?
I don't know.
Good question.
OK.
So--
AUDIENCE: Relative
to the emitter
of the electron [INAUDIBLE].
GANG CHEN: Relative
to the emitter
of the electron, relative to--
the question is relative
to what was the observer.
I think it has to be
relative to the observer.
AUDIENCE: So the wavelength
is always depending
on where you are observed.
GANG CHEN: Yeah, should
be, right we say--
if you think about Doppler
effect, a moving object emit
and you have
different wavelengths,
depending on the speed.
OK.
So lambda equals, say, h over p.
And what they did is shoot
the electron on aluminum foil.
So aluminum foil has atoms.
And when you-- it's periodical
arrangement of atoms.
So when you have a wave
come in and the waves
see a periodic structure, you
have constructive, destructive
interference.
You have diffraction.
So they only go to
certain directions.
So what they observe
is they transmit it,
if you look at the
different directions,
transmitted electron
has spikes at the angle.
And that established
the evidence,
the electrons of waves.
So all those people got
Nobel prize, of course.
And so this in fact is the
foundation for the tools
you'll be using.
Some of you use in research.
The typical Transmission
Electron Microscope, TEM.
Microscope, right?
So how it works?
One way is you use a very
sharp tip, [INAUDIBLE] tip.
You have to apply a
voltage between this tip,
a high voltage.
You drive the electron out.
So this is a field mission, when
your voltage apply high enough
on tip, the electron get enough
energy to go overcome the--
jump to the vacuum.
OK This is a field emission.
You can also heat this tip.
That's a thermal emission.
Get the electron out of the tip.
And then you apply
another high voltage
to [INAUDIBLE] this electron.
And typically,
you say TEM people
will say how good is a TEM?
It typically means how short
is the electron wavelengths?
So you actually want
to [INAUDIBLE] electron
to very high velocity,
and typically TEM voltage
is about 100 keV,
100 keV, kilovolt.
So that's the voltage
applied to the electrons.
And then say you got the
electron focusing optics.
So it's electron optics,
not the normal optics.
And then focus the electron
beam to a very small spot,
and they look at-- because
of the wavelengths,
depends on the momentum.
So the higher voltage,
the shorter wavelengths.
So you can look
smaller structures.
And you can do
transmission mode,
look at the reciprocal space.
This is the diffraction
pattern, or you
can look at the real space.
So this is a TEM.
And the other is SEM,
scanning electron microscope.
And it's similar in terms
of driving electron out.
And what it does is, say,
you look at the reflection.
So in this case,
TM is transmission.
So you have to think
the sample very thin.
And that thickness is typically
2,000 angstrom, or so.
So that the electron can
go through the sample.
You look at the other side.
So that's transmission.
And SEM is, your
electron comes in,
and you look at the
reflected electrons.
Scanning electron, so you
scan your electron beam
on the surface.
And in that case,
you don't actually
accelerate the electron to
100, typical SEM voltage
is about 20k.
And 20k is still pretty high.
And the resolution
is not as good as TEM
because the voltage.
So this is-- in terms of
what led to the wave particle
duality.
And at the time, there
are a lot of young people.
If you look at the
Heisenberg, Dirac, say, they
were all in their 20s and
took this idea and developing
the quantum, say,
the description
for the quantum mechanics.
And so we have Schrodinger.
Schrodinger is an older guy,
but he's younger than me.
He was in the 30, 35 or 38
range, Schrodinger equation.
So it turns out before
Schrodinger Heisenberg
developed matrix description for
the wave description of this.
So matrix based
quantum mechanics.
The story was that
in one summer school,
Schrodinger was
in a summer school
and learned about de Broglie's
idea of material wave.
And somebody say there
should be a wave equation
there for this material way.
So Schrodinger wrote the
equation, the way the equation
for the material wave.
And this is a h bar square
2m and Laplace operator.
And this is the wave function.
And plus potential
times the wave
function equals i h bar the
time derivative of this wave
function.
So that's the
Schrodinger equation.
And Schrodinger,
himself, didn't know what
does [INAUDIBLE] really mean.
And if you look at the-- take
u, this u is the potential.
So if you have an electron,
you have a particle, what's
the potential constraint?
And let's say if
we take out this u,
you think of this
as a temperature.
That looks like a heat
conducting question.
The first order of time
derivative, second order,
space derivative.
Now heat conduction is
another wave equation.
So the magic came from that i.
this i is a negative
square root.
That's the imaginary
number there.
You think about it, any
other equation that has i,
is there any other equation
in physics that has i?
AUDIENCE: Euler equation.
GANG CHEN: Euler equation.
Where is the i?
AUDIENCE: e to the
i pi [INAUDIBLE]..
[LAUGHTER]
GANG CHEN: OK.
So what it has is beside
say, the wave function,
is a function of space and time.
And at the time,
Schrodinger didn't
have a right interpretation.
And it was Born gave the
right interpretation,
but this caused a lot
of trouble because Born
say this wave function, itself,
is not an observable quantity.
And it's the psi times
the complex conjugate
because normally,
if you solve this,
you get an imaginary
number there.
What does the magic number mean?
So this complex conjugate
will give you a real number
and of course, this
will be a number
that depends on time and space.
And the interpretation is
this is the probability.
And this is the probability--
density function-- of
finding this particle,
at this space r and time t.
This interpretation
caused a lot of trouble
because that means
everything is uncertain.
It's a probability,
you have uncertainty.
And Einstein didn't like it.
And Einstein never agreed
with quantum mechanics.
And Schrodinger
himself didn't like it.
He even regret he
wrote this equation.
That's what I heard.
But say, this was a really
the foundation that we use now
for a lot of things.
So if you read the fight and
the debate, although say,
it was Planck who discovered
Einstein because if you say--
at the time-- Planck was
very big shot in Germany.
There's Max Planck's
Institute, that's Planck.
And he was a very
established and Einstein
was a patent clerk.
And Planck was the editor
for this [INAUDIBLE]
for physics, the physics.
And so when Einstein
send paper, he actually
published his paper.
Even though Planck
himself didn't quite
understand his paper.
This relativity, right?
Nobody claim they understand it.
But say later on, I say
this fight between Einstein
and the quantum mechanics
people got very, very hot.
So let me just make
a clarification.
This is Laplace operator.
So it's whatever, if in
the Cartesian coordinate,
it's whatever we
had you do the--
this is Laplace.
And now since cosine here is a
probability density of finding
this particle, in say
location and time,
so you have a normalization.
And in probability, at the
end, finding the particle
in the space you consider is 1.
So the normalization
for this probability
is the wave function
integrated over the space
of the whole domain that
you concern should be one.
And because it's a
probability, so there
is the expectation value.
And it turns out in
quantum mechanics,
everything is uncertain.
The space, the momentum, the
energy, the time, everything.
And you have to calculate
what's the most probable value
and what's the uncertainty
with that associated
with this expectation.
So we have expecting value
and out of any quantity,
this could be--
so we use this one is
now a number, expecting
value of any quantity
is integrated over,
again, the same volume.
And the wave function,
for that quantity,
normal representation
is an operator.
So this quantity in quantum
mechanics is an operator.
So we have the
operator operates,
say, the complex conjugate,
and wave function operate--
operator operate on the
wave function and times
the complex conjugate.
So operator operates on
the function following it.
What does that mean?
So let's ride the operator
for a few common quantities.
For position it's easy,
that's just a normal r.
But for momentum, this
operator now is a derivative.
Say a momentum operator
is minus i h bar gradient.
So this is the
gradient operator is
d dx in Cartesian coordinate
i and d dy, J and d, dz k.
So now if you put it here,
this wave function goes here.
So it's a d plus
i dx, d plus i dy.
That's the operator.
You take that
derivative and then you
do the complex conjugate
and you integrate,
and that's your
expectation value.
And for energy, that
operator is Hamiltonian
and you can actually
think about the momentum.
So it's the kinetic
energy divided
or plus the potential energy.
So is 2m, that's
a kinetic energy,
plus the potential energy.
And now, the p is operator.
So if you do your,
say, i h square.
And this Laplace dot
product give you--
well, gradient operator
dot product give Laplace.
So what you have
here is minus h bar
squared 2m Laplace
plus the potential.
Potential is a function.
It's another gradient.
So you can just--
it's the product.
So you can go back to look
at the Schrodinger equation.
This is the kinetic
energy, potential energy.
And that's what we have there.
Now let's look at
the first thing
about the general solution
for the Schrodinger equation.
I want to get the time
dependent term out first.
So for that, I assume
the potential energy
as a function of space only.
It's not a function of time.
This is not always the case.
For example, when I
want to solve a problem,
light interacts
with the electron.
And in that case, I have
a time dependent potential
because the light interacts--
the interaction will
be time dependent.
But for the moment, I
want to find the only,
given a potential, what's
the energy of the system.
So I say a space dependent,
but time independent potential.
And in that case, if you go look
at your Schrodinger equation,
you say here--
this is a time dependent.
This one is space.
This one is space, so I can
use the separation of variable
to separate the
time and space part.
So I'm going to
write, in this case,
I'm going to say, time,
space, into a separation
of variable space
and time function.
And if we substitute
into the equation--
So if you stop into this
equation, what you find
is I have psi h squared 2m
the Laplace operator psi
plus u psi equals i
h bar y and dy dt.
So this is the same as we solve
any separation or variable
problem.
This is space dependent only.
This is a time dependent only.
So the only way they
equal to each other
is each of them is a constant
of that separation of variables.
So let me use, you
know that constant
is E. It's not an incident
I use E. Because this E,
it turns out, is the energy.
So this part is easy to solve.
It's the first order of
differential equation.
When I solve it, what I have
is y is a function of time
is exponential.
So say a constant times
exponential minus i, E over h,
times t.
So E over h, I just use
another notation omega.
If you think of
this as E is energy.
Let me [INAUDIBLE] So
it's minus i omega t.
So that's the time dependent.
And the space
dependent term, once I
have the separation of variable,
the space dependent term--
now is, you see here is I
multiply this E times psi.
So what I have is the plus
u minus E psi equals 0.
So this is a time-independent
Schrodinger equation.
And this is the one
that you use when
you want to solve most problems,
what's the energy of matter?
What's the energy
of the electron?
you say crystal?
What are the allowable energy
of atoms vibration in crystal?
This is the
Schrodinger equation--
time independent
Schrodinger equation.
And the difference of this
is, if you look at it,
what's different for each
problem is really this u.
It's a potential that this
matter wave, electrons, atoms,
what's the constraint.
They're constrained by
different potentials.
And there's different potential
give you different energy
state of the matter.
A few more comments on
the Schrodinger equation.
And I said this is a separation
of variable here this is, E.
And in fact, you can go to
show because we say the energy
operator, where is my
energy operator here?
Here, energy operator is h.
So it turns out that
h, if you substitute
using what's the
expectation value
and go to use the
Schrodinger equation,
you'll find out that this age
expectation value is actually--
I'm not going to go
through all the math--
so that's suppression
of variable, constant E,
represent actually the
energy of the system.
The allowable quantum
energy quantum states.
And the other comment
is this equation,
you actually use the
equation to solve E.
So this is different than
you saw the heat conduction
equation where you give
boundary condition,
you find the temperature
distribution.
It's an eigenvalue problem.
This E is what you want to find,
given boundary condition, given
potential, you typically
have a eigenvalue--
allowable value-- for that E.
That's the quantum constraint
give you, say, not all
the energy of the system.
I say any energy, but let's
say the allowable value.
A few more comments.
Because the wave
function is probability.
So we have basic relation.
One is the Heisenberg
Uncertainty principle.
You all have heard this.
So any value has
its spread, right?
Expectation and the
standard deviation.
So if we define the standard
deviation, the other q equals--
typically, we define the
standard deviation as this q.
That's the operator-- remember--
minus the expectation
value square.
And the expectation value.
That's how we define
standard deviation.
This is the operator.
This is expectant value.
So operator minus
expectant value.
And again, you operate on--
you're putting this into
your expression omega.
That's how you calculate
the standard deviation.
And the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle
tells you is, for
example, momentum
there's a copper [INAUDIBLE].
Momentum and space
are the two conjugate.
And you can never reach
a precision better
than h bar over 2, h bar,
itself is h over 2 pi.
And the same for
energy and time,
you can never do better
than h bar over 2.
So this is the
Heisenberg uncertainty.
And finally, after
a day or so, we're
going to solve more
Schrodinger equations.
My final comment is, again,
from Schrodinger equation,
we're not proving--
you can manipulate the
Schrodinger equation.
And the way you do
it is, for example,
here is real, you
multiply complex conjugate
on both sides.
And a second time, you take a
complex conjugate and multiply
it by real.
And then you take the
difference of the two
and what you get here is
a continuity question.
So what do you have, in that
case, I will get the square.
So that's the probability,
density, time derivative
of that probability
density times a flux term.
The divergence of
the flux equals 0.
So this is like a
mass continuity.
And this j is a mass flux.
So the particle flux
in the quantum term.
So this is flux is i h bar 2m,
let's see, the wave function.
And we need this
expression later on,
when we look at
what's the electron
reflection of the interface?
If you do charge
transfer, you need
to look at that how they
interface will scatter
or reflect the electrons.
And that's a material wave.
And we'll also do what's
electromagnetic wave
reflection of the interface?
And in fact, later
on, will be starting
with two different equation.
Maxwell equation for
electromagnetic wave.
And electron equation for
the Schrodinger equation.
And you'll find for
all those waves,
the final expression of
reflectance is very similar.
So any questions here?
Let me recap.
It's a lot of material.
That's a basic for
a lot of things.
So what we have for
a material wave,
and it's [? compelling. ?]
At least,
let's say, I like to use
Schrodinger equation.
Physicists actually like
to-- they're different.
There's three different ways
to do quantum mechanics.
You can go Heisenberg that you
can do matrix representation.
And then you can go Dirac and
this Dirac operator quantum
mechanics.
And then a lot of physics books
is reading in operator format.
And you go to read
papers, most of the time,
they are actually
reading operator format.
I'm not familiar with that.
Schrodinger equation is
the master equation here.
And the wave function--
so it's like kinetic
energy, potential energy
and time dependent term.
And this psi is
the wave function,
it doesn't have meaning itself.
It's only through the complex--
the wave function multiply
the complex conjugate
that gives you the probability
of finding this matter
at certain space and time.
And because of that,
everything in the quantum world
is probability-based.
So you have the expectant value.
You have standard deviation.
So you have the uncertainties.
And that's the
basic idea we have
when you say what
we introduce today.
And what I want to do
next, I promise you,
as I say every week I want to
go to look at some journals.
And then we looked at
that last Wednesday.
And this is the Wednesday.
So what journal
you want to look?
You can ask me questions
while I turn on the projector.
AUDIENCE: Applied physics.
GANG CHEN: I like that idea.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
So it turns out the
simplest solution
of the Schrodinger equation
in the past was pretty much
academic exercise.
And say, every
book will take that
as their first solution
of Schrodinger equation
because that's the
simplest mathematics.
Now it was the problem--
I talked in the last
lecture, there's
a film with standing
wave inside.
That's 1D.
A film, so you have
boundary condition.
And the energy solution--
what's the energy quantization?
What goes through
that mathematics
in the next lecture.
But you have seen
in the last lecture,
that's the simplest solution.
The energy quantization.
So in the past, this
was really considered
just an academic exercise,
but that changed in 1970s.
And that's because
people start--
well of course, the people have
looked at some film deposition
for 400 years.
But in 1970, there was this idea
of if you deposit perfect film,
you actually can
make quantum wells.
You can see the
energy quantization.
And this was by [INAUDIBLE]
and [INAUDIBLE]..
And they actually made the
super lattices multilayer
of thin films.
So it was suggested to look at
the Applied Physics Letters.
I didn't coordinate with him,
so that was a suggestion.
And this Applied
Physics Letters.
Let's see, research highlights.
Let's look at a few
research highlights.
I did actually look
at it this morning.
So what I found is let's go to
the last two of this research
highlight.
So I say here, you have two.
One is reduce, let's see,
improve photo response indium
arsenide, gallium arsenide
quantum dot infrared detectors.
Now you can say the quantum dot.
The energy quantization.
And the next one is the effect
of electron blocking layer
on the piezoelectric field in
indium gallium nitride, gallium
nitride, multiple
quantum [INAUDIBLE]..
So under the quantization is why
did they explore, particularly
in photonics field, to
make a better lasers,
better detectors.
And so let's go a
little bit deeper.
No this is not the
paper, this is actually
the paper beneath it.
That's the one I should click.
This is a quantum dot.
So what you will see, the energy
band diagram that's drawn.
So it's a thin films layer.
And it turns out
that this quantum
dot, indium arsenide
quantum dot,
is when they grew those films.
So it's through this molecular
M-beam, Molecular beam,
epitaxy.
And you have a heated cell
you do ultrahigh vacuum.
You don't want any junk there.
And this molecule, say the
atom were say, evaporated.
And goes to a target
at a control rate.
And when you grow this indium
arsenide film, it's a crystal.
Normally you should do a
film, but because the lattice
constant is very different,
so they are string.
So once you grow to
a certain thickness,
they cannot grow
out film anymore.
The stress it will
break them up into dots.
So that's how people make
those control the quantum dot.
And then when they
are very small field,
you see here how much--
2.2 monolayer.
ML is the mono atomic layer.
And in that case, the dots
may be just a few nanometers.
And you have energy
quantization.
And these are some examples
of an energy band diagram.
We'll learn more in solid,
but essentially, you
see this is the energy diagram.
Last time, I say a particle in
I say a standing wave, right?
So this is a film,
the standing wave.
And those are different
energy levels.
If it's a half
wavelength, so let's say,
full wavelengths, there are
different energy associated.
And with that, you
can be responsive to
different wavelengths of light.
So this is just one example.
And in fact, a lot of this
are very simple cases.
You learn in
classroom these days
is being used, of course, with
complication of real materials
and not the ideal solution
that you see I give on board.
But say the basic
ideas are there.
And that's what I'm hoping
you take those and you can--
don't get afraid, you can start
reading some of this paper
and get familiar with the world.
Not only what are you doing,
but what others are doing.
Any questions?
Let me just go to the next one.
Make a few comment.
The next one is a
gallium nitride.
What's so special
with gallium nitride?
angstrom [INAUDIBLE]
GANG CHEN: It's a wide bandgap.
And in the past--
so gallium arsenide,
the previous one,
is a longer wavelength.
So the semiconductor
laser, first you
have red, gallium
arsenide based.
And people want to
have green and blue.
And a lot of people
spend a lot of time
trying to develop blue lasers.
And first, they look
at zinc selenide.
And so you look at the band
gap, we'll talk about band gap
later on.
Let's say nobody can make
them very successfully.
So there was a guy in Japan.
His name is Nakamura.
And he was not a PhD.
He was in this company called--
I think it's [INAUDIBLE]
And they supported him
for a long time, he
had a master's degree.
He was playing with
a gallium nitride.
And he was able to make
them lase and emitting light
at the blue.
Everybody was shocked.
Because nobody was working
on gallium nitride.
People were looking at
using [? sunlight, ?]
their direct [INAUDIBLE]
because it's hard to grow this.
So-called gallium nitride.
That was in the '90s.
And since then, people
making optical device,
making electronic device.
And again, say if you
grew very thin films,
you can have that energy
quantization, the quantum
wells.
In the case of
particle, it's dots.
It's quantum dots.
A film is a well.
It's actually a 1D
problem, 3D problem.
So wait for next lecture,
we'll solve the 1D problem.
I'll stop here.